حجاره متراكمه شكلت كوابيس متلاحقه لسبعه
ايام لكنها اسوار اخفت وراءها مخاوف اكبر
تتمثل بطبيعه الخطوه التاليه
السوريون واتراك وضربوا على انتظار مؤلم
رغم فقدان الامل واخرون بداوا لملمه ماسي
الكارثه والخروج من مرحله الانكار لا
منازل لا اعمال لا مقتنياتنا والاقصى
افراد عائله اقل
معظم مجري ما كان عملي كل شيء دمر صحوه من
هول الفاجعه اثارت مخاوف مئات الالاف من
التجمد بردا في العراء درجات حراره شديده
الانخفاض لا ترضعها خيم قماشيه او ثياب
خفيفه كما لا تحمي اطفالا من نزله برد
مسكنه الجو بارد وسنتجمد هنا حتى الموت
اذا جلسنا داخل الخيمه فسوف نتجمد ياتي
ذلك وسط تحذيرات متزايده من كارثه ثانيه
اكثر ضررا من سابقتها تنبع من تاخر وصول
فرق الطوارئ والمساعدات لملايين المشردين
فالالاف ينامون في سياراتهم قرب الانقاض
كثر كانوا في العراء بظروف متدهوره ومروعه
مع صعوبه كبيره في الوصول للوقود والمياه
والكهرباء وامدادات الاتصالات
منازل مؤقته او فنادق خطه الحكومه التركيه
لاواء الاشخاص الذين دمرت منازلهم او من
يخافون العوده لابنيه صامده بشقوقها
ومهدده بالسقوط
فالرئيس التركي تعهد بعدم السماح ببقاء
المواطنين في الشارع واعاده بناء مئات
الالاف من المباني بسرعه وان كانت تعهدات
بعيده المنال على حد وصف الكثيرين لكن حتى
هكذا وعوده لم تدس عتبه السوريين اكثر من
خمسه ملايين شخص يضافون الى اعداد مماثله
بعثرتهم الحرب خلال السنوات الاثنتي عشره
الماضيه هؤلاء سيتشاركون نقص المعونات
وظروف السكن الصعبه وبروده الطقس
وفي وقت يتواصل تمشيط اكوام الانقاذ
الشاهقه بحثا عن نفس او صوت يطفئ قلوبنا
ترتجف حسره وبردا يفضل ناجون العوده
لمنازلهم المتضرره بشكل بالغ لحفظ كرامه
اب لا يريد لاطفاله امراضا او امراه
انهكها موت معيل